you both you push the release of your
album you're new I'm going to honor
George Floyd how are you interpreting
this moment in our country because
you're of the younger generation and
you're very powerful and and I think
we've all been really impressed with how
the younger generation is handling all
of this how have you specifically been
handling it thank you
yes well the first couple of weeks when
everything was happening we were
definitely just very sad and I feel like
collectively in our community of our
black brothers and sisters it's like
this collective feeling of just trauma
when something like that happens because
for me personally I think of my little
brother we think of our dad that could
have been them so we just are trying to
do everything that we can to continue to
lift each other up with our voices and
demand justice for what's right I mean
our color of our skin should not be a
death sentence people deserve to live a
beautiful and long life just like
everyone else exactly I mean crazy
that's not a given subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel please don't make me keep going